ich bin hier bei der ESA gerade 5 m über
dem Boden in der Herz Chamber hier
wurden 100.000 kleine blaue Pyramiden
installiert und zwar an der Decke an den
Wänden und auf dem Boden aber was genau
macht die ESA mit diesen 100.000 blauen
Pyramiden aus Schaumstoff die
europäische Raumfahrtagentur hat ja
einiges an ungewöhnlichem Equipment aber
schaumstoffpyramiden in einem 600
quadratm großen Raum und nein das hier
ist nicht einfach ein besonders groß
geratener schallraum was hier passiert
ist weder höher noch sichtbar und
trotzdem ist es wichtig für jeden
einzelnen von uns weltraumorganisationen
reißen sich darum den Raum für ihre Test
zu benutzen und er ist bereits jetzt für
das ganze Jahr ausgebucht aber wir
durften rein also haben wir unsere
Sachen gepackt und sind zur Europäischen
Weltraumagentur Gefahren herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video auf Dr
Watson in nordweg in den Niederlanden
ist einer der größten Eser Standorte und
tatsächlich war en wir ja schon mal da
als im Dezember 22 eine Ariane 5 Rakete
ins welteil geschossen wurde war ich
live dabei das Video dazu findet ihr
hier was an dem Tag aber auch passiert
ist wir standen vor dieser Tür einer Tür
zu einem super speziellen Raum aber wir
durften nicht rein denn in diesem Raum
finden extrem sensible Messungen statt
die für die europäische Raumfahrt super
wichtig sind umso glücklicher waren wir
dann als ein paar Wochen später die ESA
einfach anrief und sagte wenn wir an
einem ganz bestimmten Tag vorbeikommen
dann dürfen wir da rein und jetzt war es
endlich soweit wir waren für euch in der
Herz Chamber der
ESA hier werden Antennen für Satelliten
getestet darunter einige Berühmtheiten
eine der Antennen vom columbusmul der is
die die Kommunikation mit der Erde seit
dre Jahren fast in Echtzeit ermöglicht
wurde hier getestet ebenso wie Equipment
für die meteosatzsatelliten der dritten
Generation das sind die berühmten neuen
Wettersatelliten der ESA über die wir
das andere Video gemacht haben und auch
Antennen für unser
allerlieblingsteleskop wurden an diesem
Standort geprüft das hat mir Benedikt
bürn verraten erst einer der
Wissenschaftler die hier arbeiten gibt's
eine lieblingsmission die du hast wo du
sagst das war ja ich glaube das das
James Web Teleskop war schon ein sehr
besonderer besonderer Moment tatsächlich
ist hier in der H Chamber aber
eigentlich jeder forschungstag besonders
wichtig denn ohne Antennen würde in der
Raumfahrt quasi nichts laufen jedes Mal
wenn wir eine Information ohne Kabel von
A nach B senden wollen sind sie
involviert für die Erde ist das
praktisch so können wir Telefone mit
ohne Schnur haben und WLAN ohne Kabel
für das All jedoch sind sie
unverzichtbar wir haben
Telekommunikation um die ganzen Daten
auch zur Erde runterzusenden dafür
benutzen wir Antennen wir haben dann
aber auch payloads wo z.B für
Erdbeobachtung wo wir die Erde mit
Antennen im Mikrowellenbereich abmessen
und genau und dafür brauchen wir halt
Antennen sie sind also für alle
Missionen super wichtig deshalb muss man
prüfen dass sie richtig funktionieren
bevor man sie ins Weltall schießt und
genau dafür gibt es die HZ Chamber bevor
wir dazu kommen was hier genau passiert
noch mal kurz erklärt wie Antennen
eigentlich grundsätzlich funktionieren
zu einem Antennensystem gehören
mindestens ein Sender und einen
Empfänger das Signal das eine Antenne
aussendet hat dabei die Form von Wellen
je nach Typ kann deren Länge zwischen
Bruchteilen eines Millimeters und
mehreren Metern variieren diese Wellen
teilen sich dann mehr oder weniger in
alle Richtungen man kann sich das so
vorstellen wie ein Stein den man ins ins
Wasser wirft dieser Stein formt
kugelförmige Wellen die sich auf der
Wasseroberfläche ausbreiten diese Wellen
kann man aber auch durch einen
geschickten Aufbau der Antenne gezielt
in eine Richtung konzentrieren das hat
den Vorteil dass so die Signalstärke
gesteigert werden kann nur die Antenne
sollte dann auch möglichst präzise
senden wenn sich Ihr Signal einen
Millimeter weiter links konzentriert als
geplant kann das viele Kilometer weiter
auf der Erde schon einen großen
Unterschied machen im schlimmsten Fall
hat man dann erstmal einen super teuren
Satelliten im Weltall der Mega wichtige
Daten über die Erde übermittelt die wir
aber nicht vernünftig empfangen können
auch bei Satelliten wie z.B denen vom
Starling System müssen die Antennen sehr
präzise arbeiten da es immer mehr davon
gibt steigt zum einen das Risiko dass
die vielen Signale sich gegenseitig
stören und zum anderen müssen solche
Satelliten die nicht immer über den
gleichen Punkt auf der Erde schweben
möglichst nahtlos von einer empf Station
zur nächsten wechseln wenn das nicht
richtig klappt dann gibt es Ausfälle und
Verzögerungen und wie sich das anfühlt
das wissen wir ebenfalls richtig blöd
kann es sein wenn man am 14 Februar
keine Nachricht sendet denn an diesem
Tag ist Valentinstag wenn ihr also einen
Menschen kennt der für euch so
einzigartig ist wie der antennenraum der
ESA für unsere Satelliten dann habe ich
was für euch verschenkt doch was von
Holzkern die Uhren und der Schmuck von
Holzkern bestehen nämlich aus
natürlichen Materialien wie Stein
Perlmut oder eben Holz daher der Name
und durch die Einzigartigkeit von
Maserung oder marmuerung ist jedes Stück
ein Unikat so wie die beschenkte Person
auch und ich finde das ist eine schöne
Metapher noch ein Argument für Holzkern
sind die schönen Geschenkverpackungen
made by Holzkern und außerdem noch die
Valentinstag Liefergarantie für alle
Bestellungen die noch bis zum 10 Februar
aufgegeben werden lasass euch aber
trotzdem nicht so viel Zeit es soll ja
nicht knapp werden besucht mal die
holzcan Website lasst euch inspirieren
und wir geben euch dafür auch noch einen
Rabatt in Höhe von 5 % nutzt dafür
einfach den Code dr 15 oder klickt auf
den ersten Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung und übrigens hilft uns
das auch weshalb ihr quasi doppelte
Liebe verschenkt oder besser gesagt
versendet und damit wären wir auch schon
wieder bei unserem einzigartigen
pyramidenraum okay fehlerhafte Antennen
können also teure Ausfälle verursachen
deshalb müssen sie richtig getestet
werden ergibt Sinn und genau das
passiert in der HZ Chamber der ESA mit
Hilfe von zahlreichen Messinstrumenten
können Sie hier alle Eigenschaften ein
Antenne messen z.B wie viel Energie sie
abstrahlt und mit welcher Frequenz oder
ob die Direktivität passt also wie
zielgerichtet die Antenne sendet aber
wie simuliert man das Weltall in einem
25 x 16 x 11 m großen Raum die Messungen
müssen ja möglichst realistisch sein und
eine ganz wichtige Rolle dabei spielen
die schaumstoffpyramiden und dazu kommen
wir gleich erst einmal zur Messtechnik
der Raum kann nämlich zwei verschiedene
Sachen das erste sind
nahfeldmessungen mit ihnen kann man die
Direktivität bestimmen also wo in dem
Raum wie viel von einem Antennensignal
ankommt dafür benutzen wir diesen diesen
Balken der hinter mir ist in der Mitte
des Raums auf diesem Balken ist auch
eine Sonde platziert und dieser Balken
kann sich nach links und nach rechts
bewegen die Sonde kann nach oben und
nach unten bewegt werden und daher
können wir eine 2D Ebene komplett
abmessen und dann gibt es noch die
fernfeldmessung wie sieht das Signal im
welteall viele viele viele Kilometer
weiter aus nehmen wir noch mal das
wasserbeispiel dieser Stein formt
kugelförmige Wellen die sich auf der
Wasseroberfläche ausbreiten in einer
bestimmten Ferne kann man dann
beobachten dass sich also keine
kugelförmigen Wellen mehr ausbreiten
sondern planare Wellen ebenflächige
Wellen denn am Anfang kommt uns unsere
Wasserwelle vom Stein noch gekrümmt vor
eine Stelle trifft uns zuerst die Punkte
ein bisschen weiter rechts und links
etwas später wenn sie jetzt jedoch
endlos weiterläuft wird der Kreis so
groß dass er uns irgendwann wie eine
Gerade Wand vorkommt und genau das
wollen wir auch hier herstellen und zwar
auf auf in einem begrenzten Raum das
heißt die Sonde die wir hier hinter mir
in diesem
rechteckigen Loch haben diese formt
diese kugelförmigen elektromagnetischen
Wellen präziser gesagt Mikrowellen und
diese Wellen werden dann an den zwei
Reflektoren hinter mir reflektiert und
zwar in zwei orthogonalen Ebenen und
nach der Reflektion an diesen zwei
Reflektoren haben wir eine planare Welle
genauso wie wie wir sie dann in 10ta000
von Kilometern im Weltraum haben die
Reflektoren in der HZ Chamber sorgen
also dafür dass sich das Antennensignal
verhält wie im Weltraum und damit der
Raum selbst sich auch so verhält wie der
Weltraum dafür gibt es diese blauen
schaumstoffpyramiden sie simulieren die
endlosen Weiten des leeren Weltalls
indem sie alle überflüssigen Wellen
einfach verschlucken man kann sich das
so vorstellen dass die Wellen
so oft hier hin und her reflektiert
werden bis sie bis sie ganz abgedämpft
werden und und quasi verschwinden ja und
daher auch die eher große Länge an an
Absorbern damit wir auch sicher gehen
dass da alles alles reflektiert wird
anderenfalls würden die
elektromagnetischen Wellen des Signals
die nicht direkt auf die messantenne
Treffen wahrscheinlich recht schnell auf
irgendeine Wand prallen die würde sie
dann reflektieren anschließend würde die
Welle auf einem neuen Kurs weiter durch
den Raum warern und im schlimmsten Fall
irgendwann ebenfalls auf die
messantennen treffen und dadurch das
Ergebnis verfälschen in gewisser Weise
sind die schaumstoffpyramiden also das
unendlich große Weltall also doch ein
bisschen wie im Tonstudio nur für Wellen
mit sehr hoher Frequenz die nennt man
übrigens auch Hyperschall die H Chamber
ist also ein hyperschallraum was wie ich
finde ziemlich cool klingt auch gegen
Störsignale von außerhalb des kleinen
Weltraums ist die H Chamber gewappnet
die Wände bestehen aus Metall und bilden
so einen phadischen Käfig der
elektromagnetische Wellen ablockt
perfekte Messbedingungen für
weltraumantennen also und trotzdem oder
vielleicht auch gerade deswegen ist das
Ganze super aufwendig man hat
normalerweise haben wir nur einen
Versuch weil weil so eine Messung kann
Tage dauern es passiert sehr selten dass
das Fehler passieren weil weil man sonst
alles von vorne beginnen müsste und wir
sind jetzt z.B jetzt schon dieses Jahr
sind wir komplett ausgebucht das heißt
wir sind wir haben ganz ganz bestimmte
Termine für die europäischen Antennen
die hier gemessen werden und daher
dürfen wir uns quasi keine Fehler
erlauben und wenn ihr dann sagt dass sie
gut aus dann könnt ihr euer Okay geben
und dann ist die Antenne abgenommen
genau nachdem nachdem wir das Okay geben
und die Antenne so funktioniert wie wie
sie soll wird entweder genau der die
Antenne oder der Satellit mit der
Antenne hier wieder abgeschraubt und
kann dann zum Startplatz gebracht werden
und wenn der Rest auch funktioniert um
dann ins ins weltalt geschickt zu werden
die HZ Chamber der ESA ist also die
letzte Kontrollinstanz für Antennen
bevor es ins weltei geht und bald soll
es hier in nordweik sogar einen noch
größeren Messraum geben also noch mehr
schaumstoffpyramiden falls jemand von
euch schon immer mal in die
schaumstoffpyramiden produktionsbranche
einsteigen wollte jetzt ist genau der
richtige Moment jetzt ist auch genau der
richtige Moment um Tickets für meine
Show zu holen drwatson.shop der Link ist
unten in der Videobeschreibung ich freue
mich auf Euch ansonsten bis dahin bleibt
neugierig euer
Cedrick